So we're going to try a few things in the Python interpreter
to get a sense of how long things take and I've
written in a procedure here that times the execution of a
piece of code. Right, we could just do the timing with
a stopwatch and then we'd have to run really long things
to be able to get a, a reasonably accurate time but
Python has a built in procedure we can use to measure
time, and that's the time clock procedure. So we could try just
using a stop watch and if we ran programs
that took long enough to run, this would give us
a reasonable idea of how long they took. It's going to
be a lot more accurate to use this built in
procedure, which is provided by the time library that evaluates
to the number of seconds. So the value of time.clock
will give us the current processor time in seconds. This
starting point is fairly arbitrary there but the important thing
is if we call it twice, and we start the
time here, and we stop the time at the second
call, we store those in the variables, start and stop,
that's going to give us the amount of time it took
to execute this code. So I've rendered a procedure that
starts by initializing the variable start to the current clock
time then run some code, and I'll talk more about
what it's doing there in a second, and then it computes
the time between the current time and the start
time, and gives us the run time, and it returns
both the results of the code and the time it
took to run. What's happening here is actually quite exciting.
So we're using Eval. Eval allows us to evaluate
any string as if it were a python expression, so
we're passing in a string here but when we're passing
the string in to eval, it's running it as code.
So we can pass at any python expression. We're going to start
and end the timer and in between, we're going to evaluate the
code and get the result of evaluating that code. So I've
defined this procedure time execution that will give us the time
it takes to evaluate any Python expression. And now we're going to
run some tests and instead of running them through the web
browser IDE like you've been using so far, I'm going to run
them directly in the Python shell, running on my desktop computer, and
the reason for that is we'll get more accurate timing measurements. You
can try running timing through the Web browser interface that we provide.
The problem is there are limits to how long we let your
programs execute and the timings won't be very accurate so instead, I'm
going to run these in the Python shell, If you have Python installed,
you can try this yourself, and we have some directions on the
website how you can do that, but it's not necessary to do
that to continue in the class. I just wanted to demonstrate how
time execution works. So let's try a
simple example. We're going to time the execution
of the expression 1 plus 1. So that's doing a
simple addition. We're adding two numbers. Well see how long
that takes and when we run time execution, we get
back two results. We get back the result which is
one plus one is two. That's good. And as the
second result, we get the time it took. A little
hard to read so it looks like 8.3 and then
E to the negative 05. So what that means That's
using the scientific notation. The negative 05 is where the decimal point is so
what that is really looks like this. There are four zeros followed
by the 83 dot dot dot and that's a value in the number of seconds.
For the number of seconds it took to run is .00008
seconds. If we try the same thing again we'll
try timing the exact same thing. We don't get exactly the
same result like the timing's inaccurate. It depends on other things
going on on the machine. We won't get exactly the same
answer. But it's still a very small number. And if we
try it a few times, we'll keep seeing this small number.
If we try, a more complicated addition, it's still going to give
us a very small number, and it's a small number of
microseconds. The actual processor time for something that simple is actually
probably lower than that but there are some other things happening because
we needed to stop and start the clock and other things to
do the timing. We'll see more if we try running longer things.
So this won't tell us much evaluating very simple, very fast evaluations.